venom is like going through a dark alley
and then like you know some figure falls
out of the sky like looks like it was
like web-slinging or something it wasn't
like a trashcan or something and then he
goes and everybody's oh it's spider-man
he pops up in it's Deadpool yeah bad
influence bad big brother to spider-man
well who better than Colossus negasonic
teenage warhead and Deadpool to get them
off the earth see opening up the door to
that multiverse and there's you know
[Music]
this is rogue theory and we were talking
about the Merc with the mouth Eric Foss
no this guy's gonna be part of the mouse
house somehow so how is Deadpool going
to join the MCU I'm Phillip Malina and
with me to go rogue are Zack Huddleston
who I mean come on off-screen producers
at this point this Homer I'm like on and
off screen producer Tommy Bechtold is
bad absolutely delighted to be here
thank you so much for having me back
everyone don't read what you think you
see in the papers as truth the media is
all lies I am NOT a lizard he's a human
and of course
yeah also later this episode we're gonna
pick sides in the debate over which
version of the rise of Skywalker's
actually the one that we should have
gotten our happy with and defend there's
three different versions of this movie
now we're gonna defend each one to the
death at least Tommy
great so guys real quick also Eric is on
Twitter everything you've been meaning
to say guys since Disney bought Fox
people have been worried about Deadpool
that's been like the go-to how would
Disney ever do Deadpool both of his solo
movies were obviously rated R they're
like hard R and then Disney has never
done an r-rated MCU movie no Deadpool
movies are even featured on Disney Plus
nope right now so this week the writer
of the first two Deadpool movies said
that there is gonna be a Deadpool 3 and
it's gonna be rated R and we know that
Kevin Feige has met with Ryan Reynolds
already so they're already working on
this new movie so I want you guys to
pitch me this dirty dirty mouth movie
this how Deadpool is going to enter the
MCU and maybe even more importantly how
an r-rated movie even fits in the MCU
please okay but you know who does you
are is Sony okay so I think they kick
dead pull over to be in venom two to
venom two so vengeance affirmed which is
confirmed and it the last minute movie
was pg-13 but they they're not opposed
to our movies like they're not like like
venom was not a children's
seven-year-old full frontal cannibal and
so but they might kick it to our this
time because just to get Deadpool into
it and Deadpool can be like
the bad influence to spiderman like he
can be like the guy who comes in and is
trying to and is saying everything that
spider-man is like against and not about
but also carnage is has been teased for
venom too right which is like basically
asking for an r-rated movie like he's a
psychopath he's murderer
so Deadpool can come in and like
high-five carnage like he can go around
and do what doing whatever he wants and
then pop right out at the end of the
movie and go back to where he came from
cuz he can just comment on everything
and the way that he gets in right cuz
it's like okay how did he get in here
from this universe like they don't exist
together if he can just comment on it
right like he can call it out and this
is the only way they won't let me into
the Disney exactly like this is the only
way he can be like well Sony does rated
R but not doesn't like he could just say
it out loud that's how we get him I
think it does fly in the face of like
legal rights these characters to like
what I really like is I could totally
imagine cuz everyone's like is
spider-man gonna be in the next bit I
mean that that was the big question
around that whole debate and people are
like it doesn't feel like it fits this
Tom Holland version of spider-man and
it's like serious dark venom story but
you could totally imagine some sort of
scene we're like venom is like going
through a dark alley and then like you
know some figure falls out of the sky
like looks like he was like web-slinging
or something it wasn't like a trashcan
or something and then he goes and
everybody's oh it's spider-man and pops
up in a cab instead because they're so
frequently like called out for having
very similar costumes yeah and like
venom could use some humor like let's be
some like non weird symbiote humor we'd
like that actually I think would improve
it I think it'd be great that's great
alright so you get a full-blown
be very limited on the road work yeah
we're going back
ran out of right yeah I know there's
pizza grease on everything over here
would be so fun Tom Hardy Woody
Harrelson the weed budget so so I think
you know people right now are hungry for
Deadpool like we there was so much when
Disney murdered Fox it was like what's
gonna happen to like this super popular
character so we think we want a full
meal of Deadpool but we don't we don't
really want that if we got Disney's
version of Deadpool as a full
introduction is like a full movie that'd
be too much so I present you mean like a
full-on Deadpool 3 that's his first
introduction I think that would be a
mistake I think you'd end up with like I
like to think of you know even though I
respect the process anchorman one versus
anchorman two anchorman 1 hard r-rating
they really went for it and get to
because the actors that all become so
famous and the property becomes a huge
they made it pg-13 and they kind of
blunted the effect so I think we need
what I call the potato salad version so
we want him in our movies but we just
need side dish of them so oh yeah we
don't need a full burger we don't need a
hot dog
I know it's ironic that I made it about
food literal and makes a lot of sense
perfect so I think what I think we're
looking at you we are we have talked
about your ant-man is kind of the most
comedic Marvel movie but I think that
guardians of the galaxy and Thor are the
silliest they're not the most maybe
necessarily the failable I would say
both of them are both of the properties
would be very funny so I think there's a
chance to sprinkle some Deadpool in one
of those two movies but only as kind of
a like patch like almost like a software
patch like we have a specific problem
that we need someone with us skills
can't be killed it can't really be
injured that can regenerate and has all
of this combat training this weaponry
training so we get kind of like a mini
mission like a sea storyline in one of
those movies involving like this is
intro yeah like maybe there's a maybe
like you know as I had talked about
before on this show like in a Thor movie
maybe there's something with the
relocation maybe they maybe there's yeah
you look where they need some muscle
they need some bodyguards well who
better than colossus and negasonic
teenage warhead and deadpool to get them
off of Earth safely yeah it's funny that
as Guardians are specific they'll be
badasses but whenever they're being like
ferried somewhere well you know it's I
think it provides more sympathetic
immigrant story to have them be like
home revolt I'm traveling and you know
have that the journey be treacherous
because it builds character as we know
from our story so I think that I think
that we're going to see Deadpool very
subtly introduced in yeah just like a
nice little paprika top you also the
weird software patch part of the got
explained to me in food so you know how
like when you're icing a cake and the
guy whose birthday it is is Ryan but you
accidentally right Brian and then you go
in with more frosting and you cover up
the B with the rose with the Rose
exactly Deadpool is the rose frosting
covering up the B and Brian's and Ryan's
birthday cake does that make sense guys
I shouldn't have taken acid before we do
this that was a mistake work that you
put in his word you took a really great
character and you made him a potato
salad patch eventually he's gonna get
his own movie this is what we get when
we get spoiled we come daddy comes home
he lays all alone gave you all this cake
you know excited this is a really well
thought out
the hope is gonna respond to this he's
gonna respect the fact that I laid out
some some thought behind it Tommy it was
a great theory it is we're saying really
I want to acknowledge that people call
us out for this is an eighth of a Rogge
technically but you see it in 2d so it's
why we call it a quarter Rogi Tommy I'm
sorry if you thought I was about to give
you validation I just want to say the
way your book ended it with apologizing
to me is all the validation
I've got a quarter apology I'm sorry
[Music]
there's no replacing anything about
Tommy yeah I enjoyed both their theories
here's what I think though so we know
one of the next MCU movies were getting
in phase four Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness okay scary stuff
you know what does scary movie needs a
little comedic relief here's what I
think and again this is just how we get
we get Deadpool into the MCU you know
Doctor Strange is doing a montage of
opening up dealing portals into
different multiverses you know this
one's all people with duck feet you know
what if Hitler won and this one is just
opens up one and kind of like opening up
the door to that multiverse and there's
you know Wade Wilson Deadpool ironing or
something like yeah Tommy and I were
talking about like him in pajama pants
with the Deadpool mask on being like
what are you doing and of course in the
very self-aware way he's like hey dude
with sideburns what's going on or
whatever right and then BOOM
that's it's just a quick it's just a
little a little nugget for the fans yes
and that's it maybe maybe we get thirty
so just as like a tweet right so that
it's like the MCU is acknowledging there
is this other multi person with Deadpool
Colossus the other x-men is out there
but like we want all these things to
exist in the same universe so they can
show up in the same movies so it's like
now Doctor Strange knows oh those people
don't exist in our reality but I can get
to them yeah if you need to rice would
you say
don't don't
so potato salad in a safe ball myself
yes
don't break glass in case of longer time
you know by the end of phase four or
whenever when we're ready for another
big team up movie whatever the next
Avengers is whether it's Thunderbolts or
Dark Avengers or Young Avengers whatever
right Doctor Strange is gonna be like
we're in too deep
we're gonna need some help that guy that
was iron yeah I know some guy in game
and like all his friends from everywhere
show up right like it'll be kind of that
same thing I think the reason they do it
this way is it allows the Deadpool
movies to keep being hard armed and to
stay nasty without kind of tainting say
nasty Ponyboy yes and there's a trend
here about quarter rogue is out for
cowardice because I want Deadpool to
just come in and smash the MCU and just
be this hard our guy needs a hell yeah I
got my own movie and if you're in my
movie try cursing it'll come out you'll
hear it it'll work watch we're in a good
place my homeland is the most vile flood
yeah but it means so many things it's no
so I give it back to me in a tweet and
maybe if I like your Toyota you can
supplement your rogue account let me
think of a rhyme no you don't need to
that's just Tommy had made that Deadpool
kicks Sony's doors down by making venom
rated R that's a good tweet yeah nice
good tweet quick good tweet that's maybe
my best tweet yet and makes the most
sense just it was a simple sentence and
that is already here I got one cuz I
don't want to follow Tommy Deadpool
deuced in the multiverse could be worse
could be multi worse I was gonna I was
gonna push you I was gonna push you and
say if you can get the multi but you did
it yourself
does xTag okay uh I think it would go
something like Deadpool schools house of
mouse a tiny potato salad to introduce
Deadpool in this adventurous ballad you
[Applause]
two just pulled ahead of marina yeah the
breast but marina actually put Deadpool
straight up in a movie yeah nobody needs
to comment further well you are my
sister's before we talk about whether or
not made up versions of Raisa Skywalker
might be better than the movie that we
actually got we're gonna give a quick
shout out some of the cool things we
have going on in new roxor hey guys Eric
here things get pretty bold here her on
the big question and really we would
love to take YouTube's parental
restrictions to the limit but
unfortunately some films they're just
too violent for us to go into all the
great detail on police publicly on this
channel so new rockstars is now offering
monthly bonus videos exclusive to our
generous patrons with unlisted links
that you can get by becoming a patron of
new rockstars Digital Studios this month
we broke down the Kingsmen church scene
frame by frame here's a clip of our
breakdown but then if we get another
sneak cut on the digital zooms that we
are back to Colin Firth here for the
most crucial acting moment of this
entire sequence see the explosion causes
momentary deafness Harry's ears are
ringing and the freebird music fades
down for a moment and Colin Firth ever
so slightly shifts from berserk
rage to awareness shock confusion horror
because the ringing eardrums have
blocked out that simcard signal then the
rain fades away
Freebird comes back and he's
lives back and a berserk rage you can
access this plus all the other great
bonus videos we've made by becoming a
patron a day at patreon.com slash new
rockstars and thank you to all of our
lovely current patrons oh god Tommy no
okay every Star Wars movie that's come
out recently has had fans and terribly
intense detractors so since its release
specifically rise of Skywalker has had a
couple leaks about alternate versions of
that movie we could have gotten
specifically I'm highlighting that there
was supposedly a director's cut of this
movie JJ's version of this movie that
was like up to an hour longer I had all
kinds of additional stuff that maybe
would have fixed some some issues as
some people had but also previously
Colin Trevorrow tomorrow I think you
said it first
Trevor oh the right uh he was going to
be the one who's gonna make this film
he's a Jurassic world guy he had his own
version of the script that recently came
out that a lot of people are loving
actually and is a pretty significantly
different movie and then of course
there's the cut that we got that a lot
of people are saying is kind of the
Kathleen Kennedy cut where it's just the
the studio itself said hey JJ thanks
don't worry you can trust me as I carry
this over here and then they chopped it
up and like reduced it down I hate you
for going to Warner Brothers and now
will ruin a lot of people think JJ went
to Warner Brothers because of history
Ben
[Music]
but I want to know right now it's gonna
be the definitive answer of which of
these three is the best one the one we
got the JJ cut or the Colin script
version so let's start that debate okay
I'll go first and I think like the one I
like the best is that Colin Trevorrow
the guy who got fired the the thing that
never even got close to getting made
unlike the the JJ cut so the the Colin
Trevorrow cut which he titled it the
duel of the fates there's gonna have a
totally different name was there's a
cool name it's this song right if you
real quick if you want a really in-depth
liquation of this guy you can watch
Eric's video where he did a great job
bringing down both the JJ cut and
counter row a potential version but the
things I liked about this is it was
primarily focused on making the three
most recent movies kind of like of a
hole right there's no the one of the
biggest differences is Palpatine doesn't
come back yeah right it's it's a little
bit more of a kylo and Array story
letting kylo kind of be the main bad of
this final movie there's also you know
there's no smoochy-smooch between him
and Rey there's this other figure that
we've never seen before there's kind of
who's Palpatine's trainer this Torv alum
i think is how i was pronounced kind of
this gross monster type figure but like
it's it's a little bit it's still
paralleling obviously the original
trilogy we've kind of Kyllo following
that anakin path to the dark side but
like it's not trying as hard to tie in
all nine movies which i just think like
the weight of that so much on rise of
skywalker right they had so many things
they need to deliver on and so much like
canon and story that like i feel like it
was it was just too much for that movie
you do and to pull off and it still be
fun and i think especially when the two
movies preceding it to exactly help yes
and of course you know trevor o wrote
this in 2016 which was before last Jedi
came out also before Carrie Fisher died
and she played a bigger role in this
movie so like that was something that
kind of would have tied the hands of
this script a little bit
but I think like this it it felt like
without going into all the plot details
and things like that it felt like a more
original movie that wasn't as maybe not
as fanservice maybe whenever it is
popular right but it felt like it would
have been more of a statement kind of
like last Jedi which I know is a
polarizing film but like I like last
Jedi and I think I would have really
liked The Trevor out duel of the fates
give us a key moment from that film that
is like this is exactly this is I think
that happens in this film that we needed
yeah well it much like rise of Skywalker
right it kind of culminates in this kind
of big space land battle on Coruscant
right with like you know Poe and and
Finn and ROS and everybody fighting on
the ground well like Chuy's in an x-wing
and you know Leia with the the Armada or
fighting in the sky and all this is
going on while ray and kylo or hindi and
commenting ray has a sick double-sided
lightsaber dog hell yeah right and like
and it's a little bit more just like
straight forward like she defeats him
you know kind of like balancing out the
force all this kind of jazz right and
like I just like that the kind of yeah I
think one of my problems with rising
Skywalker was the like hinting at
something and then taking it away right
hinting at somebody turning and then
hinting and somebody's dead no never
mind right like there's so much of that
like so many people we thought were dead
came back and whatever and like this
movie is just like a more like
straightforward propulsive kind of plot
yeah so it sounds like it's less about
the force honestly because remember all
of the Jedi versus all of the that we
can definitely understand is like okay
this settles a lot of things it sounds
like this version maybe isn't doing that
yeah it feels more like Return of the
Jedi
Pizza I'm interested I wish I could see
it that's worth a full quarter Road
quarter right
okay all right I do I wish that it would
still involve the force of that shirt
and bring more to it but there are some
exciting elements and to be fair we've
only seen like an outline of this script
and I'm sure like whatever the hundred
and twenty pages there's a lot of more
detail about that we haven't heard that
kind of stuff yeah yeah but is very
interesting the idea that leaving
Palpatine outlets our characters that we
cared about two previous movies rise to
take the central roles yeah they're less
pawns in their own story I like Zach
serie but can I say why mine's better
okay so all the problems that people had
with rise of Skywalker are fair like
fine you know it was rushed or it felt
rushed not the production was rest but
the editing felt fast paced like we have
to come here we have to go there
everybody and each scene is like you
know maybe 30 seconds we never like sit
and live in anything and that would be
solved entirely by having the JJ Abrams
director's cut which is better than the
theoretical version of a script because
we and this is a stretch but sometimes
when blu-rays are released you do get a
director's cut so it's not outside of
the realm of real world possibilities
that we might not get the 40 the extra
40 minutes but we might get something
which like I'd rather have that like
that sounds like that sounds tasty to me
and every problem would be solved
because the time all the complaints of
like oh this is rushed would be solved
with an extra forty minutes and you're
sitting at home and you can everything
is explained the Kyllo ray battle on the
end in the water is explained more
clearly his death and rebirth is like
laid out specifically the the Janna
character is confirmed it's explicitly
said that he's that she's Lando's
daughter and all the things that you
just said are like they're teased like
they would be laid out we see Finn use
the Force
there is also still no kiss so all those
haters would be like satisfied or
whatever and there's more rows which I
think is important because as a as a
person who watched last Jedi
and a person who watched rise of
Skywalker if you cut everything out like
all the commentary all the like
everything outside of just watching
those movies it's jarring to see such a
huge character in last Jedi all of a
sudden go to 30 seconds of screen or 7
minutes or whatever 7 lines of dialogue
at screen time it's it's genuinely
drawing like just as a movie goer which
i think is an error like the complaints
aside like internet internet commentary
aside like harm the the flow of the
series so you would get that would be
solved you'd get more rows you get more
development from all the characters the
only thing is you have to do that you
would be like detraction is like get up
in the middle and go take a peek when
they show movies they do literally turn
the lights on stop the movie and give
you a pee break entry these they solve
all the problems they could write there
could be an answer to every scene in
there oh yeah it also includes
live-action force ghosts which is indeed
that they shot that's the rumor is that
there would be included so we'd so uh I
just think if that cut comes out it
won't but if it did the imagine being in
the theater and getting that moment
everybody in the theater would be
screaming yeah everyone shows up instead
of like hearing and having to recognize
for newsboy describe bills a lot of
potential then also specifically it not
only does it explicitly say what Finn
wanted to tell ray yeah just that he's
for sensitive but then
uses yours a little bit and it's like
yeah this is the end of the whole thing
what are we saving yeah what are we said
I know that from reading that that they
just had bb-8 so you still took the
screen time right yeah it's like they
specifically were like let's make it a
little worse weird but ya know I'm
pretty into this this film this JJ cyst
that's a cute way to say sister short
right Tommy though what are you
defending your own take on this this is
really great guys I love both of your
theories I also love unicorns and
leprechauns but that doesn't make them
real so to me honey go to Regal and drop
$12 cuz it exists and you can see it
today
it's the theatrical release of rise of
Skywalker and let me tell you why this
movie's got it all the main villain in
Episode one the Phantom Menace Senator
Palpatine who is the final villain in
rise of Skywalker Emperor Palpatine okay
it comes full circle it completes the
saga in a very satisfying way and baby
to those to kiss you better believe Rey
and kylo Ren lip-locking is a
problematic you better believe was fine
I don't think we need to tinker with it
I think it completed the saga that we
set up obviously the fans were very
divided after last Jedi JJ & Co had a
pretty insurmountable task of wrapping
this all up in a satisfying way and I
think they did and I think what they
also did was in concluding that saga
they created kind of new avenues for
exciting new Star Wars properties rather
than just being like let's leave this
open-ended so maybe there'll be a Star
Wars 10 of the Skywalker saga we don't
need that now for me rise of Skywalker
answered the questions that I had in a
satisfying way and created new
possibilities that I think are fun to
explore and I don't think we
I think sometimes we can use these
theoretical versions of other things to
just cast our own wishes our own light
fantasies for how these movies would
wrap up but that's not the way it works
movies are made independently of our
thoughts and feedback I mean there are
certainly polls supersonic they took his
gorgeous human teeth from his mouth one
at a time I wanted him to have ripped
legs and gorgeous human teeth no he's
got little squirly legs or Hedgehog legs
and cartoonish teeth and it's not real
enough for me anyway I just felt like
the cut that came out was the perfect
version of it yeah for me I think that's
a passionate defense and I appreciate it
so far no rogue ease but I hit but it's
goes weak here's what I want from you I
want you to specifically take these two
on so so why is competeing being there
which I think it goes against that's why
is that necessary because we cling to
stories with a identifiable villain a
monster villain that seems
insurmountable I mean what is the theme
of these movies the good guys even in
moments of weakness they lose their arms
anakin skywalker before he loses his
arms and legs loses one arm Luke
Skywalker loses one arm Palpatine gains
an arm back at the end of the movie is
arm grows back it has to be a specific
choice there's all of this symbolism
he's this massive bad guy it makes the
most sense for him to be the final straw
before they can really truly restore
peace to the galaxy okay and then
specifically your version that you love
why is it served worse by more scenes in
does the JJ code I don't think that
they're necessary I mean I don't think I
think that making the movie longer
doesn't make it better I don't I think
that that is it the irishman begs did if
they only had one more scene where
Robert DeNiro explains ALPA Chino that
if he didn't stop messing with the mob
they were gonna kill him I think it
would have got the seven wasn't enough
no but I think I just don't think that
I don't think I think Lando and Janna
being related is condescending and it
kind of implies a little bit like well
they're two black people they must be
really I'm sure that's an easy point to
make it sounds like always right and I
will say to echoed Tommy's point about
like lunker's not better I had a friend
that it would always make the joke about
deleted scenes like it's the equivalent
of going to a restaurant being served
spaghetti with meatballs and the waiter
coming out and being like here's a
couple other meatballs the chef didn't
really think you don't necessarily need
more I guess of the two for sure
the JJ Abrams version of the to
theoretical versions out there is the
one that is more interesting to me to
explore so it's a little harder to
directly compete with you however I am
right the argument is just we don't want
to have to pee in the middle you've made
it very hard because I was gonna give
you this other Rogie and then you said
specifically that marina's was better
but then you did end with the phrase I
am right and you did precede it by
saying you're a white man this is turned
into a very special episode how about
like Rises Skywalker hell no stick with
your boy Trevor oh okay alternate cuts
that smells like butts original recipe
is the best of these theories new cut
from JJ that's what I'll say
[Laughter]
nobody tweets in rhyme is
that's not even is but Tommy
I appreciate your tweet the most and you
get therefore but I it's never gonna
happen there's a good reason that he may
get probably but even though Tommy's in
the lead now it'll probably change the
road question the upcoming streaming
service peacock will feature a rebooted
Saved by the Bell in which Zack Morris
is now Governor of California that's
where they were headed what legislation
has governor Zack Morris recently passed
no homework oh you can eat any animal
you want Morris doesn't follow any rules
yeah you see a an alligator in the road
you can cut its head off I think I think
he best is the law that anybody in the
state of California can turn to the
camera and talk the teaser for Fast and
Furious 9 came out and teases Dom
Toretto's child being an important part
of the movie give me your best toddler
Toretto racer impression I only live my
life a quarter mile at a time without
your family you're nothing if you look
out there and don't see family in front
of you you have no chance of success
that's podracing picture me in a Hot
Wheels when I grow up I'm gonna drink
co-owner I think none of those are
accurate because Dom Toretto is child
would have a deep
guys this weekend is the Super Bowl yeah
we ought to say that what's the best big
game party snack and why but you must
sing your answer the best party snack is
a slice of pizza rolled into a taco cuz
it fits right in your mouth it started
like you were singing the Folgers yes
for me it's very simple to make your
party right don't skimp on the shrimp
people will lose interest in the shrimp
then you eat all the shrimp alone after
two shrimp most people they're full but
not me I can have five or six maybe
seven or eight it's a date just me and
the shrimp the jumbo shrimp you severely
underestimate and the average person
stomach to shrimp and we're full I don't
like shrimp okay again I should have
tried to sneak ahead of Tom because it's
gonna be hard to follow but how about to
the tune of Drake's hotline because no
one whiter could have possibly done this
it is perfect
I could have picked a Willie Nelson so I
chose hotline bling don't know why I
like that pizza taco mouth 3 3 and 1/8
looks like two and a half two and a
quarter three and a quarter
sounds like Tommy Tommy we have to
explain this Tommy's wishes that
everyone has to introduce us Oh to the
evil version of themselves that evil
Marina has straight hair and she wears
it like very much in front of her face
and she goes around poking holes and
everybody's theory but she never comes
up with one of her own she's just like
that's wrong because of this I mean she
is evil Tommy has has retreated to a
fortress very very far north north of
Canada where he lives growing his hair
and beard out dressed only in red
surrounded by little people who make all
the toys he demands that they make and
once a year he goes out on his magical
sleigh with nine reindeer and throws the
toys down the chimneys of unsuspecting
girls and boys tricks or treats you
decide he's just Jack Skellington Wow
evil Zach does not have that kind of
mythology behind him I think evil Zach
just always takes up two parking spots
unfolds all the shirts at the gap you
know and leaves them just like crumpled
so you can't find a larger medium when
you need to and definitely eating grapes
straight out the supermarket like not
paying for those
yeah yeah with his fingers that's a
given that all these people are very
racist alright well that's it for this
episode of rogue theory thank you guys
so much you can find the evil versions
of ourselves yeah at Marina master us on
Twitter when I'm real cranky I'm
skipping my thing to shout out my boy
Ilan who I saw who came to my work and
said hello Ilan you are the man thanks
for being a fan Gino's West pizza comes
to town Gino's masters were evil time
and you catch me on the new rock stars
discord server chatting it up every
Monday with Twitter I love you guys
[Music]